kurz bevor das video losgeht noch eben
eine sache von mir und zwar gestern der
fdf das heißt sie waren ein bisschen
feiern und ich hab mich ein bisschen
erkältet und das ist schon fünf und es
ist dunkel draus und ich habe jetzt
keine lust noch wirklich ein richtiges
video hier neu aufzunehmen mit
belichtungen als ich habe allerdings auf
meinem pc noch ein video gefunden das
von max aufgenommen habe so von wegen
marx verkleidet sich wieder als martina
und ich schneide ihm die haare und er
reagiert dann so als frau so ein
bisschen darauf von wegen alters wie die
haare geschnitten sowie das verläuft so
lifestyle youtuber machen von wegen alle
zwei tage in die neue haare wollten dass
damit ein bisschen hoch nehmen das ganze
video ich wollte es eigentlich hochladen
aber ich habe jetzt gedacht ich gebe
euch lieber das video dann anstatt heute
gar nichts hochzuladen also vielleicht
gefällt es euch hallo mein name ist luca
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen video wenn man durch youtube
stellt man wenn man jetzt ein bisschen
durch youtube trends stöbert sieht man
immer häufiger videos wie sich leute die
haare färbe oder haare schneiden lessing
habe ich mir gedacht ich habe eine
freundin die kennt ja auch alle und zwar
ist das hast du irgendein hahn auch ach
du willst jetzt quasi weil du von lucy
geschminkt wurde es auf seinem kanal hat
ja jetzt gedacht so wird das deine haare
geschnitten hat bekommen das ist ein
komplett losbekommen
das passt gut weil ich habe mir extra
dass nämlich das thema vom heutigen
video das ist meine freude martina und
sie hat unfassbar lange haare deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht weil sie gerade mal
schneiden wir einfach mal die haare das
ding ist ferner die haare fallen nicht
mehr so wie sie sollen gesagt ich mir
ein bisschen kürzen lassen wir machen
euch vertraut hier also als würde ich
halt von der länge auf jeden fall sein
ordentliches stück abnehmen dass hier
würde ich auf jeden fall
falls es nicht so viel wenn ihr das so
viel ist dann tut mir leid martina aber
jeder professionelle frieser macht das
das ist eine neue taktik wenn man zuviel
abschneidet dann kann man jetzt einfach
wieder anklingen
okay machen wir es erstmal ab und dann
können wir ein bisschen rum experten mit
einem plus
okay okay wenn du mich auch noch was
ihre eltern werden jetzt einfacher so
ein bisschen durchgehen das ist jetzt
ein bisschen oder mal wieder halb halb
beruflich im achten weltkrieg
ich glaube wir machen jetzt mal einfach
echt so ein bisschen zeit was willst du
haben genau also eine seite lang wie
andere komplett kurz nehmen müssen die
haare doch ein bisschen abnehmen ja auch
jeder seite war ich nicht ganz das
potenzial aber nur ganz kurz
denn ich habe das nie wieder machen so
haben wir hier noch so ein bisschen was
weggenommen jetzt machen wir's mal so
ein bisschen wie es an der seite kurz
fassen aber auf der anderen ein bisschen
runter hin was du verstehst look
genaugenommen look die haare kannst
jetzt nämlich so wie justin bieber hat
ja keiner mehr so richtig
auch dieser film muss ich die seite aber
noch kürzen oder wie willst haben also
eine sind komplett kurzem hier ist
wirklich machen weil das habe ich echt
schön geschnitten finde ich ja ich
glaube ich mache es einfach alles auf
dieser höhe
ich sag dir wenn du zeit hast also ich
hab jetzt auch schon ein bisschen
erfahrung für solche schäfer nimmst du
die ganzen schönen haare weg und es wird
direkt bereue es sehr viele youtuber
machen das ja gerade derzeit ist sie
quasi sich einfach die haare färben
abrasieren was auch immer damit machen
was wir hier allerdings gerade versuchen
ist wirklich die maschine hat sich das
gewünscht ist jetzt natürlich ein
bisschen krass wenn man hier so viele
haare abschneidet was ist dir gewünscht
da muss natürlich durch nur ich mach das
jetzt alles so wie ich meine wir kommen
jetzt hier auch schon zum letzten
haarstrang schneide ich jetzt einfach
mal so komplett ab und dann müssten die
quasi schon länger jetzt haben richter
kurzzug herum
ich finde es sehr schön hier für dich
cool jetzt mal ein bisschen in ansatz
danke
als 2000 jahre später das grab meiner
arbeit machen wir haben jetzt auch
letzten sind sondern youtube werbung
gesehen dass es nicht zum film blade
gibt es gibt es ist kein placement oder
so für diese rasierer aber damals soll
es angeblich gott meine haare hab ich
das so gut ausgedünnt aber wir sind ganz
viele kleine tierchen nur ausgesucht
fast drauf also ich habe eine werbung
gesehen von diesem rasierer und dann
habe ich mich letztlich kaufte ihn mal
und wenn es wirklich so klappt wie in
der werbung war rasiert sich einen
kompletten strich
auch mal bei dir sca drei jahre ab und
probiert man hier durch die haare
irgendwie durchkommen die buga wieder
kann er das auch hätte nie gedacht dass
jedoch so stark sind ich mache jetzt mal
hier ein strich zur 1
der frisst sich dann durch den rasierer
da kommt nicht alles raus was ihre reize
was martina ich probiere jetzt noch an
deinen haaren einen etwas gewagteren
look und zwar willst du nach diesem
video füße ich bin fitter so können wir
doch alle haben geholfen wird
ich kriegte er nicht ab gerade bist du
dich auf deine haare viel zu sehr
abgeschnitten
mal nichts geworden ist wie sagst du
schon hin zur glücklichsten herr weise
schön geworden
das einzige was für mich zählt liebe ja
definitiv nein
ok martina ich zeig dir jetzt was sie
gerade kreiert haben schau es dir an
hundefutter bis z wie auch schön ist sie
so independent aus freunde das würde ich
sagte was jetzt auch vom heutigen video
im gratis haarschnitt
das was jetzt hier von video meine damen
und herren ich habe leider keine and
card mehr aufgenommen
irgendwie war das ganze video komplett
umstrukturiert die schon zu beginn des
videos gesagt und wie ich auch mehrmals
während des videos gesagt habe solltet
ihr das ja alles nicht ernst nehmen was
ihr gerade gesehen habt sondern maxime
ich haben uns einfach gedacht so okay
wir waren in den youtube trends
unterwegs und alle möglichen komischen
kanäle im bios hochgeladen wo die sich
hier abgefärbt haben und dann wieder
geschnitten haben und dann locken
gemacht haben und dann fast eine glatze
und alles mögliche und es ist irgendwie
total lächerlich fanden wir haben uns
halt gedacht hey wie können wir das
ganze irgendwie auf die schippe nehmen
und unseren senf irgendwie dazu geben
und haben dann halt gesagt ok max kommen
setzt sie wieder ein paar rücker autos
als seine frau martina und dann tue ich
welchen friseurin scheidet wie hart wir
machen das sei nahezu komplett gestellt
mit von wegen wo mein gott stellte mir
die haare ab scheiße überhaupt nichts
gegen leute die das als ihren content
standardmäßig alle paar wochen bringen
wie sie sagen dass in meiner neuen haare
und das ist voll krass und dann
irgendwie ins ziel was packen mit an
irgendwie gefakten blau gefärbten oder
so das weiß ich jetzt will kann verstehe
ich einfach nicht zu den halb darum aber
wie gesagt jungs mit humor das war ein
bisschen komisch chaotisch ich wollte
wie gesagt eigentlich gar nicht bringen
aber dann habe ich mir gedacht kommen
bevor ich jetzt heute wirklich nicht zu
schade leidig die über dieses video hoch
damit ihr wenigstens was habt stellen
wachsen ich euch vielleicht trotzdem
unterhalten konnten last auf jeden fall
mal gerne ein like da schreibt bald in
die kommentare
wenn ihr jetzt gerade noch dran seid das
schon schon krass wenn man sich so ein
video bis zum ende gegeben hat ich nehme
das ganze gerade mit der iphones
elfenkämper auch deswegen keine ahnung
ob wir gleich mal die eingeblendet wird
oder davon wegen meinen kanal abonnieren
deswegen sage ich euch jetzt einfach
weißes bild gleiche hin und als sie dann
einmal ein video eingeblendet von max
pfizer stück der welt gemacht haben und
auf der anderen seite ins mai da könnt
ihr einen kanal abonnieren also das war
schon video haut rein tschüss